not quite sure how to define your makeup
Vibe it might be written in the stars we
rounded up some of the best makeup looks
for your star sign Aries you've got all
the glow Taurus go for something
Timeless and classic Gemini is gemis too
obvious cancerians you need something
warm and natural Leo it's got to be
fierce Glam viros you're all about
Immaculate liner Libra go for something
deep and romantic Scorpio you suit
something Smokey but soft sags you love
a pop of something bright and fun caps
keep it pretty and practical Aquarius
you need something individual and
alternative Pisces for you it's all
about something soft and fresh want to
know more about why that makeup suits
your star sign check out our article
online